I mean don't you think that's enough no
never enough Timmy Timmy please yes
Demi please
hey everybody so we're here at the Honda
Civic Tour future now we're Demi Lovato
and Nick Jonas are preparing for their
big tour across America today I'm here
because their fans are about to make a
bunch of decisions for them on Twitter
it's a Twitter adventure Demi Lovato and
Nick Jonas let's go it's gonna be great
it's gonna be great
nice to meet you nice to meet you yeah
be nice to meet you let's get down to it
you guys are going to send out things
and all of your fans are gonna decide
what you're gonna do for the rest of the
day I think leaving my daily choices in
the hands my fans is a great idea you
look so nervous yeah I'm nervous they're
gonna decide what I do you know you left
Twitter for 24 hours I did so I owe it
to my fans yeah you should give them the
opportunity to control you Twitter I am
your let's have you tweet right now
we're about to do a taste test we're
gonna send out on your Twitter which of
the gross foods are gonna choose
sardines
crickets baby food you know they're
gonna pick the crickets I don't think
the crickets are actually saying I think
they're Jack what if I barf on you well
then that'll be a great rest of the day
you know I'm a sympathetic vomiter so
I'll just pass it along what I think
baby foots got it you guys are eating
baby food okay oh that's nasty
no no it's thanks baby Thanksgiving
which which means what it's turkey gravy
and stuffing I think who wants
Thanksgiving who wants Peas
I'll happy I love Thanksgiving yeah
this is your fault
mmm hey my days like peas yeah great
good for you this tastes like
Thanksgiving apparently I'm gonna treat
I love you guys I'm in great thanks with
them she's in great thanks with whoa
whoa whoa so you're gonna tweet out
right now
Demi needs your makeup done presidential
her soul should I help reply her makeup
or should she apply her eyeliner with
her non-dominant hand so nervous yeah I
don't want to walk around with koch2
eyeliner it will be Baba's for good you
should have confidence and have you
transferred out Meyer I was talking
about my lip you're gonna do great you
need to have
confidence you know my confidence is
getting there it's real close that's one
of my songs I know no and I never follow
her on Twitter or not me I do follow you
oh no all right we're gonna we're gonna
follow and we're gonna get the mix of
the emotions in this is too much don't
put me and just got LASIK no big deal
just hold your face still place your
hand is shaking it's adding an extra
element of intensity I was made for this
it's not bad it really is not bad it's
really nothing I was like almost falling
yeah
I'm so impressed I'm so impressed
thank you anytime but you look right now
uh you guys have both sort of faced up
against each other but we had a few
requests from people that they wanted
you to prank somebody
well Kelsey is not in here and she's my
assistant she's really fun - both great
well let's quit the internet wanted you
to do is a glitter bomb silly string or
an air horn so we're gonna have you
tweet that out
can we just say about to prank somebody
yeah for sure
great so the internet shows glitter bomb
but we decided we're just gonna do all
of it okay everything's going great so
far Nick's got the glitter Demi's got
the air horn
well we missed her with the glitter
entirely but otherwise that one great
man we're sorry
it was terrible pranking people I'm
sorry but that was bad your litter was
awful subpar no it was so bad it was bad
so we need to find out which one of you
two is ultimately the best person either
ping pong great equalizer or motorized
scooter race but it's going to be up to
both of your fans to figure it out okay
let's do this alright so why don't you
put it out on your Twitter but you
retweet it that's it so we're gonna let
that time passed so your Twitter
followers said scooter race so there's
your scooters we're gonna have you race
from here all the way back to your
dressing room on your mark get set go
you started early oh sorry
Nick starts out as a chick gotta fix
that Eileen Debbie you did it crushed
him hey question like a tiny bug thanks
like a tiny little grasshopper you've
got crush I'm a better birthday so now
you get to ask your Twitter followers
what's it in to me cuz I make you do all
this nonsense you just sent out to all
of our fans the punishment for me which
will either be a bucket of ice water
pies in the face or she's gonna give me
an atomic wedgie which boom a lot of
people would love to have an atomic
wedgie from you oh I don't think that's
a thing you would want in here no no but
it's true thank you're still just as
nervous as when we started because I
don't know if I'm gonna have to reach in
your pants and give you a big one you
needed Emmy oh that's it guys we did it
and your fans chose unfortunately to
dump a bucket of ice water over me so
that's what we're gonna do any last
words
just three huge celebrities hanging out
land with Twitter I'm saying everyone's
equally attractive laughter don't laugh
louder when you're called out on it